in late 2020 variants of the virus that
causes covid19 were discovered around
the world
first one in the uk then more in south
africa and
nigeria the question is what is their
significance
in public health terms government and
health officials
acted swiftly to try to contain the new
versions of the virus
we must therefore go into a national
lockdown which is tough enough
to contain this variant but what is a
variant and why
are they such a problem well let's start
with the basics
viruses are microscopic infectious
agents
and scientists debate whether they're
even alive that's because they can only
survive a limited time
outside a host cell once inside a cell
they take over its machinery and make
copies of themselves
over and over that's how they spread an
infection
so how does a virus mutate well
when it replicates random errors can
occur in its genetic
code that's the instructions for making
a new virus
these are called mutations and most
don't make
any difference but sometimes they give
the virus new properties
this is one of the reasons the flu
vaccine has to be updated
every year vaccines train the body's
immune system to fight the virus
but if the virus mutates and changes too
much a vaccine may no longer work so
what is a variant then well
when a virus mutates it becomes a
variant a slightly different version
if the mutation gives it a new
superpower like infecting more cells or
spreading in the air more easily
then it will make copies of itself
faster and become
the dominant version of the virus the
only way of detecting a new variant
is by taking samples from patients and
doing a readout of the virus's genetic
code
something the uk is very good at over
the last few days
thanks to our world-class genomic
capability in the uk
we have identified a new variant of
coronavirus
which may be associated with the faster
spread in the southeast of england
and likely why it was the first to
discover a significant variant
the concern about this particular
variant of covid19
is that it spreads more quickly our
scientists have confirmed
this new variant is between 50 and 70
percent
more transmissible that means you're
much much
more likely to catch the virus and to
pass it on
that led to a surge in cases starting in
kent before spreading across the uk and
beyond
the third national lockdown is an
attempt to bring the virus back
under control
[Music]
you